in this lesson we're going to talk about
solving equations and related expression
so this is something that comes up on
the s80 and various forms know how do
you solve an equation and then use that
to solve another expression so it's kind
of like a multi-step problem we'll go
for a couple examples in this video just
so that you can see you know how to
approach these types of problems so
example one says it's 4x minus 3 equals
13 what is 8x plus 6 equal to okay so go
ahead and pause the video sleeping
install this one on your own we'll go
through together so here they're not
just asking us to solve for x you know
they're actually saw asking us to solve
for 8x plus 6 right but you can do this
in two steps you could say well let me
just solve for x i'm going to add 3 to
both sides right so that's going to give
us score x equals 16 and then divide
everything by 4 so you can see that x
equals 4 then you can put floor into
this expression here that's going to be
8 times 4 plus 6 which is 32 plus 6 okay
so 38 is our answer so that's just a
multiple-step type problem you're
substituting you know and then
simplifying the final expression now
let's look at example 2 so example 2
says if 2 minus X divided by M equals 8
& M equals 4 then what does m divided by
X equal ok again it's just like a
multiple-step problem so let's go ahead
and get into this one see if you can
solve it and we'll go through it
together so the first thing is they're
telling us that M equals 4 let's put
that in place of em here so we have 2
minus X divided by 4 equals 8 what you
can do is you can cross multiply across
the equal sign okay so that's going to
be 2 minus x times 1 is 2 minus x equals
4 times 8 is 32 subtract two from both
sides so you get negative x equals 30
and divide everything by negative 1 so x
equals negative 30 right but then it
says what does m divided by X equal well
M is 4 and X is negative 30 so if you
reduce this by dividing the numerator
and denominator by 2 you're going to get
2 over negative 15 or you could say
negative 2 15
so this shows up on SATA one or two
times and it's basically just like a
multiple-step type problem so don't get
intimidated by it just try to solve the
first expression substituting the second
expression and then keep going from
there so if you need to review this less
than otherwise i'll see you in the next
lesson